Traduttore: TEDx Milano Translators
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Quando ho deciso di fare il medico,
e quindi mi sono iscritto a medicina,
questa mia decisione era dettata
in maniera molto forte
da una figura, dalla figura
del nostro medico di famiglia,
che veniva a casa da noi
quando stavamo male.
Visitava me, visitava le mie sorelle,
e poi si tratteneva a chiacchierare
amabilmente con i miei genitori.
Altri tempi.
Probabilmente, anzi
sicuramente, altre figure.
Nel scorso, però, dei miei studi
mi sono poi ritrovato
a vedere pazienti con leucemie,
pazienti col cancro
e quindi sono scivolato
verso un'idea diversa della medicina.
Un'idea diversa,
nella quale mi piaceva personalmente
l'idea di poter dare un contributo,
senza nulla togliere al medico di famiglia
di allora e di oggi, ovviamente,
ma un'idea diversa di medicina
che voleva cercare
di fare qualcosa in più.
La vita poi è, come sapete, un po' buffa.
A volte una lettera può cambiarci la vita.
Questa è una lettera
che io ho ricevuto nel 1984.
Vedete, è ancora scritta
con la macchina da scrivere,
in cui l'Associazione Italiana
per la Ricerca sul Cancro
mi comunicava di aver vinto
una borsa di studio per l'estero.
Era una borsa di studio
per un periodo di tempo limitato,
che io ho utilizzato
per andare a lavorare a New York.
Andai a lavorare a New York
in un centro di immunologia,
dove nell'84 si iniziavano a fare
le prime esperienze
di immunoterapia dei tumori.
Poi, un po' come capita
nella vita di tutti quanti,
ci sono rimasto 6 anni.
E quindi a un certo punto,
a 29 anni, 30 anni,
mi sono ritrovato
un po' davanti al bivio:
resto? ritorno?
Ho deciso di ritornare,
in qualche maniera accettando un po'
una scommessa con me stesso,
di voler provare a mettere in piedi
un progetto in Italia
che coinvolgesse persone di alto livello
nell'ambito dell'immunoterapia dei tumori.
Direi che questa scommessa,
almeno questa scommessa, è stata vinta,
perché oggi a Siena abbiamo un centro
in cui lavorano oltre 50 persone,
molti di loro ricercatori attivi,
nell'ambito dell'immunoterapia dei tumori.
Ma cos'è l'immunoterapia del cancro?
È sostanzialmente
un cambio di paradigma assoluto
rispetto a ciò
che noi abbiamo utilizzato
nell'ultimo secolo, direi,
per trattare i tumori umani.
Questa è una vecchissima diapositiva,
che io ormai uso da probabilmente 30 anni,
che in qualche maniera identifica,
anche in sequenza temporale,
le strategie che noi
abbiamo avuto, abbiamo
e in qualche maniera avremo a disposizione
per trattare i tumori.
Fino alla fine dell'800,
c'era solo la chirurgia.
Molte volte una chirurgia
devastante, inutile,
perché non aveva la possibilità
di portare a casa risultati importanti.
Poi, agli inizi del '900,
abbiamo cominciato ad avere a disposizione
anche la radioterapia,
che ha dato certamente un contributo,
e continua a darlo,
al trattamento dei tumori umani.
A questa poi, negli anni '60
ha fatto seguito la chemioterapia,
che è stata vista negli anni '60
come la strategia definitiva,
che avrebbe combattuto
in maniera definitiva i tumori umani.
Però, già negli ultimi
30 anni, direi, 40 anni,
c'era un gruppo sparuto di oncologi,
che, in giro per il mondo,
riteneva che questo
non fosse sufficiente,
e soprattutto che riteneva,
nella quarta sfera
che vedete colorata in giallo,
che si potessero utilizzare
le nostre difese immunitarie
per combattere il cancro.
Era, se volete, un gruppo di visionari
che si ritrovava in tutti
i convegni internazionali,
alla fine del convegno,
nella sala più lontana,
quella più sperduta.
Ci si parlava anche un po' addosso.
Ma che aveva le basi razionali
per continuare a pensare,
in maniera molto pervicace,
che fosse possibile utilizzare
il nostro sistema immunitario,
cioè quello che noi abbiamo all'interno
del nostro organismo, tutti noi,
e che ci permette di sopravvivere
nell'ambiente esterno, quotidianamente,
per combattere il cancro.
Questa diapositiva io l'ho utilizzata
tantissime volte per dire:
"E poi c'è l'immunoterapia,
che è una strategia promettente".
Bene, non è più così.
Non è più così perché l'immunoterapia
è la quarta strategia, oggi,
che abbiamo a disposizione
per combattere il cancro,
e quindi per sradicarlo dall'interno,
utilizzando il nostro stesso organismo.
Che, vedete, è in grado,
nel corso della nostra vita,
della vita di tutti noi,
di tenere sotto controllo e distruggere
delle cellule che decidono
di diventare immortali,
quindi delle cellule tumorali.
Questo accade.
In alcune occasioni, però,
queste cellule diventano
talmente capaci di sopravvivere
che sfuggono a questo controllo,
e quindi abbiamo
l'evidenza clinica del cancro.
"Sfuggire al controllo" significa
che le nostre difese immunitarie
non sono più efficaci.
Sono state messe fuori gioco.
Con l'immunoterapia noi cosa facciamo?
Cambiamo completamente il paradigma.
Non utilizziamo più qualsivoglia
delle tre strategie
che abbiamo utilizzato
negli ultimi 100 anni,
bensì utilizziamo dei farmaci,
che sono dei veri e propri farmaci,
per potenziare le difese
immunitarie del paziente.
Quindi non dirigiamo più
la nostra attività verso il tumore,
bensì la dirigiamo verso
il sistema immunitario del paziente.
E quando siamo bravi a far questo,
e quando abbiamo
tutti gli ingredienti giusti,
riusciamo ad ottenere
delle risposte cliniche
che sono spettacolari, lasciatemelo dire,
e che in alcuni tipi di tumori,
penso al melanoma cutaneo,
che è un tumore della pelle
per il quale, fino a pochissimi anni fa,
non avevamo assolutamente nulla
da poter offrire ai nostri pazienti,
oggi abbiamo più che triplicato
la sopravvivenza di questi pazienti,
a 10 anni dall'inizio della terapia.
Quindi stiamo ottenendo
dei risultati estremamente importanti
che in alcuni tumori
sono andati oltre la chemioterapia.
Ad esempio, il melanoma.
Ma certamente ci sono tanti altri tumori
sui quali stiamo lavorando
e abbiamo ottenuto
dei risultati importanti
che sono oggi a disposizione di tutti,
che sono oggi a disposizione
di tutti gli oncologi,
non solo fuori dall'Italia,
ma anche in Italia.
E quindi abbiamo farmaci
che funzionano bene
per il cancro al polmone,
il cancro della vescica,
dei tumori testa-collo.
È una lista che si allunga,
un po' come una galoppata trionfale,
quasi ogni settimana.
Quasi ogni settimana otteniamo
ulteriori informazioni
sull'efficacia di questa
strategia terapeutica.
Quindi un cambio assoluto di paradigma.
C'è però da dire che -
io sono un entusiasta,
perché ho sempre lavorato nell'ambito
dell'immunoterapia dei tumori.
Sono entusiasta di quello
che sta accadendo oggi.
Ma c'è da dire che la comunità
scientifica internazionale,
anche quella che è stata
assolutamente scettica
fino a qualche anno fa,
fino a pochissimi anni fa,
ha preso coscienza
che quel gruppo di visionari
qualcosa in testa l'aveva.
Aveva degli elementi per immaginare
che si potessero ottenere
dei risultati importanti.
Quindi oggi l'immunoterapia
viene vista da tutti,
anche dagli scettici,
da quelli che non ci credevano,
come una strategia
assolutamente importante
nel percorso terapeutico
dei nostri pazienti.
Ed è inutile dire
che molti di quelli scettici
oggi son diventati degli esperti;
ma questo fa parte delle cose,
della natura delle persone.
Quello che però
è assolutamente importante
è guardare al futuro.
Cioè andare oltre
ciò che finalmente
siamo riusciti a ottenere,
dopo decenni di insuccessi.
E questo è assolutamente possibile
perché noi oggi abbiamo
le basi scientifiche, le basi cliniche,
per comprendere
come migliorare la possibilità -
migliorare la percentuale di pazienti
che risponde ai trattamenti
immunoterapici.
Perché comunque,
anche nella migliore delle ipotesi,
noi abbiamo che circa il 50% dei pazienti
non trae beneficio
da questo tipo di trattamento.
Ma gli ultimi decenni non sono passati
invano anche in questo senso,
perché noi, grazie alla ricerca,
siamo riusciti - noi
comunità scientifica internazionale,
a comprendere i meccanismi intimi
che regolano questa -
abbiamo visto una danza
molto bella prima -
in questo caso particolare,
che regolano una danza a due:
quella fra il sistema immunitario,
il nostro sistema immunitario,
quello che è dentro tutti noi,
e il cancro.
Questa è una danza che per funzionare
richiede moltissimi elementi.
Richiede che noi conosciamo profondamente
le radici di questa interazione.
E le radici di questa interazione
sono complesse,
perché sono da un lato il tumore
con tutte le sue sfaccettature,
tutte le sue caratteristiche
e tutte le sue diversità,
e tantissimi meccanismi che mette in atto
per sfuggire al controllo
del sistema immunitario.
Dall'altro lato, quindi,
abbiamo però le nostre difese immunitarie
che sono in qualche maniera
diverse fra tutti noi.
Hanno un livello diverso di efficienza.
Quindi,
solo se riusciamo a mettere insieme
in maniera ottimale questi due attori,
riusciamo ad ottenere
il miglior controllo della malattia.
Ma a questo si aggiunge
complessità su complessità.
Stiamo imparando che il tumore
si nasconde al sistema immunitario,
non solo cambiando
le proprie caratteristiche,
ma sviluppando una nicchia,
all'interno della quale vive
il cosiddetto microambiente tumorale,
che molte volte utilizza
le nostre stesse difese immunitarie,
alcuni tipi di cellule
del nostro sistema immunitario
per difendersi dal sistema immunitario
che abbiamo attivato
in maniera specifica con dei farmaci.
Quindi c'è molto lavoro da fare.
C'è moltissimo lavoro da fare,
ma abbiamo una base, come dire,
fantastica di lavoro,
che parte non solo dai risultati
che abbiamo già ottenuto,
ma dalle conoscenze che continuiamo
ad acquisire giornalmente
anche sulla funzionalità
del nostro sistema immunitario.
E in quest'ottica mi piace ricordare
che lunedì scorso, questi due signori,
Jim Allison e Tasuku Honjo,
hanno ricevuto il premio Nobel
per la loro scoperta fondamentale.
Nei media avrete sentito
che avevano storie toccanti di amici
che avevano avuto il cancro.
Niente di tutto questo.
Loro non erano interessati al cancro.
Loro erano interessati a capire come
funziona il nostro sistema immunitario.
E ci sono riusciti,
perché sono riusciti a comprendere
che la funzionalità
delle nostre difese immunitarie -
tutti i giorni, in questo momento,
in ciascuno di voi -
passa attraverso l'interazione fisica
fra le cellule del sistema immunitario
che si parlano fra di loro
per ottimizzare il controllo
di ciò che è estraneo,
attraverso delle molecole di membrana.
Da questa scoperta fondamentale
che ha permesso di capire che esistono
dei circuiti regolatori negativi,
quindi che spengono
la nostra risposta immunitaria,
si sono poi generati dei farmaci
diretti, in questo momento,
prevalentemente contro due molecole -
una si chiama CTLA-4,
l'altra si chiama PD-1,
che sono in grado di spezzare,
di bloccare questi segnali negativi,
quindi che mantengono e potenziano
l'attività del nostro sistema immunitario.
Che a sua volta è poi in grado,
in circa il 50% dei pazienti,
come vi dicevo,
di tenere sotto controllo
il tumore e di eliminarlo,
e di permettere ai pazienti di vivere,
e di vivere molto più a lungo
rispetto a quello che
ci si sarebbe potuto immaginare.
Quindi, questi due signori
hanno certamente contribuito
in maniera fondamentale
ai successi dell'immunoterapia di oggi;
ma partendo, quindi lavorando
sulle radici del funzionamento
del nostro sistema immunitario.
È un po' come parlavo qualche giorno fa
con un amico, grande produttore di vino,
che mi diceva:
"Per fare un grande vino
bisogna conoscere le radici,
bisogna sapere in quale terreno
affondano le radici,
altrimenti non potrai mai riuscire
ad ottenere un grandissimo vino".
Grazie.
(Applausi)